so today I want to present you our work
new Meza we call it cyclically
immunofluorescence it's a highly
multiplexed height on the image platform
that you can use to clothing post
decreasing power and the tissue section
so let me try to quickly go through the
general master that we are using for the
slightly no fluorescence so the the goal
of the second immunofluorescence is try
to extend your capacity to do compared
to the traditional in the North or xx
that's typically limited by the spectrum
so you can do like four five once that's
at most but by using a repeated standing
and a be standing master we can now
spend our capacity to up to thirty
different antibody at once that's on my
t-shirt simple so that mean it goes to
our master that cycle email addresses so
as you can see in the message here the
the basic concept is really easy so if
you stand do whatever you are standing
first like you do for a traditional
versus then we use the chemistry master
that we can just delete or you take you
say bleach then fluorophore then you can
do it again and again and try repeat
this message
now you can achieve that multiplex image
in the sense and home so like in here a
simple case you can show right here in
the master part it's that we have first
first thing that it's the the full color
that we do for the new cast and then you
do this we call a fourth rock which in
the message now you can stand for four
different antibody in the sensor that
you can see that now you change to a
cytoplasmic stand although you probably
cannot see details like what value are
we using whether the concept we can use
for the balls in control cell like in
here you can see individual cell that
stung in 96-well plate and also we can
adapt the same answer to the slide so
that allows you to do with tissue sample
clinical sample and then the same
concept can a bright for the old type of
tissue or old hat example and the here
so on the top our result our first
result you can see right here so let me
try to go through more detail so if you
can see right here this corner so we
have performed we call the cyclotron
resonance or cited that in 96-well plate
and then we've done like ten cycle of
sizes that allow you to probe at the
same time ninety thirty different
antibody that's give you very first
thing is very very enriched data that
you can do a bunch of the single-cell
analysis that people cannot do before or
you can only achieve with other inch
very expensive instrument like a cycle
or something else so and also these
things can be though not just for the
quantitative study like we here to show
it as 10x image but we can also do
something like even more high resolution
from here we show it's like high content
image we done in a confocal microscope
then that the things you can do 60 X
image now you just look at one single
cell and that you can put like all
different subcellular localization
13 as well as some some forceful signal
at once so that's kinda our advantage to
use this a new highly multi parts image
platform
okay so now we shift here a little bit
right we can also use the sensing with a
little help from a company of real sight
we now can use the same kind of concept
and doing with the liquid biopsy in here
we demonstrate it's a human bra then we
can actually try to find a circulating
tumor cells in the blood sample as well
as not just identify yourself but also
at the same time try to pull all the
thing kind of marker that associate with
tumor progression so a same concept that
we can use for not just clinical sample
also more research set up so in the next
things we show that we can try to
dissociate a mouse brain and make simple
cells spread unless by using the same
technology that we are using for the
human blood then we can prop up all
night in here we do a form of standing
already gives you 12 yes 12 different
markers now you can do a clustering
analysis as well as high dimensional
representation in two dimension that's
basically why you can see here to
identify the specific sub population the
most interesting idea here is now you
can treat this as image cytometry
messer but at the same time you can use
the case concept the sensitive antibody
try to do it in situ so here is the is
one and associate the mouse cream so you
use the same type of antibody and to try
to cover it again and then you can try
to each trade a single cell they have
found this impact issue now you not only
have the single celled ichabod also at
the reach special information for
example you can see a kind of clear here
you have some some cluster of the signal
together now you can see what kind of
different cluster in different region so
and also then we quickly move from the
more research set up between non
clinical Sarah
now we can poke the sensing on the tumor
sample here we call it digital and
modern practice knowledge now you can
see this kind of beautiful picture I
sorry I don't have time to go over it in
detail but now you can use your
imagination and also your available
antibody to do a bunch of combination in
the same tissue and in the end will be
very interesting to see so now we just
winging from one particular case here is
a pancreatic cancer cell and now you can
actually eat straight each single cell
data and do this we call a digital
representation as you can see in right
here so you can clear see it's captured
almost under percent of the image shown
here but not only that you can actually
each tray all this single so data and
try to do a dimensional reduction will
show before that in image cytometry
setup and as well as try to see all kind
of signaling correlation in this kind of
specialist every solution so in the end
we just want to put proof of concept
back the oldest kind of measure can be
acquired for different type of tissue so
we use the tissue microarray that come
in 30 different tissue and also for each
teacher will have to like tumor
associated we start a bigger issue and
we run through like a run of standing
and again 24 different antibodies
standing and now you can first see like
you can do a bunch of a very cool spot
with this thing but first thing we just
want to demonstrate it's actually very
clearly distinguished from teacher to
teacher you can see right each color
will be same one tissue and the after
dimension reduction to part into two
dimensions you can now see the
individual island of different issue and
also we can kind of see so in the middle
part here you can see that red part is
the tumor sample and the blue part is
the normal tissue now you start to have
the ability to distinguish
human tumor and normal tissue using this
time of technology and also using go
through like just one humor time in here
we go through that just pancreatic
cancer in different stage now the things
we found is in the early stage of
contracted cancer you can see they are
more close to the their original they
are urging normal tissue that's the
pancreatic tissue but if in the late
stage you start to see this kind of
fussy if you know type that we collected
originality of this tumor so now it's
not just far away from the original
tissue and also they are also more
diverse from the itself so in the end I
just want to say this still is a very
like new technology we are still charter
developer and optimized feel free to
email us if you have any question and
then where I want to order collaborate
and also my advisor keep us over and
also science for a chance to present in
this wonderful conference thank you so
much